hello everyone i'm xingpong from foden
university china welcome to my talk
multi-dimensional analysis of cloud
native software based on large-scale
operation data
in this talk i will first introduce the
concepts of cloud native software and
the microservice architecture then i
will explain why cloud native software
evolves to complex ecosystem after that
i will analyze the challenges and
opportunities of cloud native software
analysis and finally i will share some
fast and ongoing work for
multi-dimensional analysis of cloud
native software
cloud native software has been a very
hot topic in both industry and academic
cloud native means that the design and
the implementation and the deployment of
an application fully exhibit the
characteristics of cloud computing for
example distributed and elastic cloud
native means a lot of things among them
i think the most features include
microsoft's architecture container-based
deployment and operation and develops
and continuous delivery according to idc
by 2022
90 of all new applications will feature
microservice architectures and 35 of our
production application will be cloud
native
uh microsoft architecture
is very important for the cloud native
software microsoft agitator means to
implement an application as a set of
small grain services each service can be
developed by a small
autonomous team and can be independently
released deployed and scaled
a collaborative software can be very
large we can see in some very large
companies their cognitive software can
include tens of thousands of services
this kind of cloud native software
includes many applications these
applications share
common service infrastructures and the
boundary of the applications phase
and in this kind of software system new
features and the business continually
emerged every day under the services of
the system continues delivered and added
and updated
so we think this kind of complex system
can be regarded as a new kind of
software ecosystem and this kind of
software ecosystem i think is quite
different from traditional software
ecosystem like android and ipo ecosystem
because for this kind of cloud native
software ecosystem
the whole
applications and the services are
continuous in operation and their
evolution are mostly online
we all know that software analysis plays
an important role in software
engineering
they can be used for different purposes
for example reverse engineering fault
detection and the testing design issue
detection and the debugging and
traditionally the techniques used for
software analysis include
static analysis dynamic analysis and
history analysis among then static
analysis which means to
use some kind of static analysis tool to
analyze the source code and history
analysis which means to analyze the
evolution history of a software usually
by analyzing the community history of a
repository these two kinds of techniques
are mostly used dynamic analysis is less
frequently used
in traditional soft analysis because
dynamic analysis is usually very
expensive
but for cloud native software we will be
faced some new challenges because the
services in cloud native software are
developed independently by different
teams and in different repositories and
running in a highly dynamic and
uncertain environment and for this kind
of cloud native software the complexity
of the system has been shifted from
individual services to architecture
level because we know that we all we
know that the services of the system can
be very small so the development of the
individual
services is not so difficult but the
complexity is quite large in at the
architectural level because as i
mentioned just now
for a large software cloud native
software it can include
tens of thousands of
services and this kind of architecture
cannot be managed in a top-down way
because the system is too large and the
different parts of the system are
developed by different teams so nobody
can have a very complete
picture big picture of the whole
architecture and for this kind of
software static analysis or history
analysis cannot help because we know
that each service in cloud native
software can has its own repository so
it means that if we analyze the source
code or the evolution history of a
repository we can only understand
the individual services we cannot
understand the interaction between
different services
but at the same time the analysis of
clone's cloud native software has some
opportunities
first cloud native software follows
microservices architecture so it means
that
this kind of software has a explicit
software architecture because the
architecture of cloud native software
a knight is naturally defined by the
services and the interactions so we call
we say that uh
this kind of cloud native software has
an exclusive software architecture at
the same time cloud native software
usually has very good
infrastructure including the so-called
observability infrastructure obviously
for cloud native software and the
microsoft architecture includes three
peanuts
they are tracing logging and the matrix
so it means that
based on this kind of infrastructure we
can obtain very rich and large amount of
data from their their long-term
long-term infrastructure including locks
traces and the metrics and this kind of
runtime data that is so called the
operation data in this talk can can
helps us to do different kinds of
analysis
so based on this kind of operation data
we can do a lot of analysis so here i
will talk about uh
multi-dimensional analysis from four
different aspects the first is anomaly
detection the second is root cause
analysis third is architectural
evaluation and the force is business
understanding
normally detection and the root cause
analysis
both are concerned with short-term
problem handling for example detect the
anomalies and
identify the root cause in a very short
time to help the developer to uh resolve
the the problem or incidence in a very
short time
activity evaluation the business
understanding are
more about
some
median or long-term goals for example
architecture evaluation will be
concerned about the long time the
long-term evolution of the software
architecture
anomaly detection means to detect
possible anomalies or incidents in the
running system
in traditional distributed system log
analysis has been widely used for
anomaly detection usually
they will extract long events from raw
log messages and the twitter log as a
sequence of log events then they can
learn
log patterns from normal execution and
detect anomalies when long patterns
deviate from the trained model in recent
years there are some researches focused
on
transfer anomaly detection they treat
our tracks as a sequence of service
invocations and learn similar to
log anomaly detection they will learn
trace pythons from normal infusion and
detect anomalies when trace patterns
deviate from the trend model
at the same time we think that the
current log
anomaly detector and the trace alumni
detection approach have some limitations
because we know that a micro service
system can include many different uh
many macros many services running in
different nodes so to understand the
whole uh behavior of the whole system
and to detect the anomalies and the uh
we need to combine the behaviors of all
the services and also their interaction
so we think that we need to combine logs
and the traces together because the logs
reflect the intra service behavior and
the traces reflect the inter-service
interactions we need to combine them
together and also we need to consider
the complex structures of traces because
we know that a trace
indicates a invocation chain for request
in the trace there are there there may
be many service invocations in the
higher in a hierarchical structure and
at the same time a trace may include a
parallel or a synchronized invocation so
we need need to consider the complex
structures
root cause analysis means to localize
the root cause of a given incident or
anomaly
usually we can combine different kind of
operation data including logs traces and
the kpis
to for for this
for this purpose in the recent work
we use service dependence graph to
do root cause analysis for specific
types of anomalies including performance
reliability and traffic in this work we
construct a service dependence graph in
this graph we have service dependencies
and the related kpis which are captured
from recent service invocations the
basic idea of this work is to traverse
the service dependence graph from the
entry node for root cause
localization the np node means that
where the anomaly or instance is
reported the key techniques in this work
include single service anomaly detection
which means to
to determine whether
a dvd individual services is
anomalous based on the kps and
traversing strategy means how to
traverse the uh surface dependent graph
in the efficient way a promise rate
which means to uh prong the the uh prong
during doing some kind of plumbing
during the traversing because we know
that the graph can be very large so if
we have no
planning strategy the whole process will
be very inexpensive candidate root cause
ranking which means that to rank all the
candidates root crosses uh in the uh in
the last step
so the challenge in this work is how to
balance between the accuracy and the
time of root cause analysis because we
know that if we want to obtain a very
precise
result of rule called analysis we can
use more time for example to
traverse the the
service dependent graph in the in a
better way but at the same time we need
to control to limit the time of the
nicest because we know that
we are handling long-term alumni and
incidents so uh the developers need to
resolve the problem in a very short time
microservice architecture is likely to
decay
and i think the courses for this problem
maybe come from two aspects uh first
microsoft architecture usually is
ongoing a very long evolution and during
the the process as the different parts
of the architecture are maintained and
developed by different teams
different kinds of issues will be
introduced to the architecture at the
same time as i mentioned just now
the microsoft microsoft architecture of
cloud native software can be very large
so it means that usually there are no
global view about the whole architecture
so different kinds of architectural
issues may emerge
for example we can see in some very
large industrial micro service systems
there exists a very long evocation chain
for example there uh i i have seen some
evocation chain include about
500 hopes in a single trace and also
there are some psychic evolutions in
some traces
and also as you can see in this slide
there are also other kinds of
architecture issues uh for example
hub-like dependence and also no cohesion
and the high country of services
and also there are some architectural
issues related to performance
availability and
scalability architecture evaluation for
cloud-native software of
based on microservices architecture
highly depends on operation data node
source code and evolution history we
know that articular evolution evaluation
you usually conducted for traditional
software based on source code analysis
and evolution analysis analysis for
example we can analyze the evolution
company
relationships between different kind of
four files based on the repository but
as i mentioned just now because in for
microservices architecture each service
account has uh have its own repository
so means that we cannot uh analyze the
relationship between different services
from the repository because each
repository only records the history of a
single uh service
uh also at the same time source code
analysis cannot help a lot uh
for similar reasons so uh i think for
microservices architecture uh the
evaluation i think highly depends on
operation data that means that we should
consider to
use traces logs and also kpis to
identify the potential potential uh
architectural issues uh for soft uh
native software
uh basic understanding in a similar i
think uh for similar reasons usually the
developers
cannot have a
have a complete
picture or view about the whole
microservice
system so uh
similarly i think we can use the
operation data to understand the
business uh
in a recent work we have
uh
have present approach that uh conduct a
multi-layer aggregation of traces uh to
help the understanding of business uh in
this work we conduct uh multi-layer
aggregation that means that uh in one
layer we aggregate aggregated the traces
by the
topology that means that all the traces
having the same tree structure will be
aggregated aggregated together and
in another layer we will further
aggregate the traces based on business
scenarios the big series here can be
indicated by key services for example uh
for given given address if the trace
has passed some key services for example
uh
order submission and also payment then
we can we can say ah this trade is about
uh online shopping yeah so based on this
kind of multi-layer allegation we can uh
we can have a more efficient view about
the trades because we know that the raw
traces can can be very large uh for some
big
microservice systems
they can produce uh billions of traces
per day so we need to use this kind of
aggregation approaches to
to provide a more efficient view for the
understanding of the whole system so in
this work we combine graph databases and
analysis analytics
databases for efficient
data analysis and uh
also we provide some uh visualization uh
for the developers to understand the
business flows and they're changing so
we can see uh based on this kind of
analysis we can provide a visualization
of the current business flow and also we
can uh we can highlight the changes for
example uh maybe this morning the the
the developed development team have do
some uh they deliver some new features
and then the business flow have some
changes so based on this kind of
visualization we can understand what
changes have happened uh for the system
so conclusion uh multi-dimensional
analysis of cloud native software is
very important so but we
need to know that large-scale connective
software has evolved to complex
microservices ecosystem and for this
kind of
complex ecosystem multi-dimensional
analysis is required for various
purposes such as anomaly detection root
cause analysis architecture evaluation
and the business understanding but
at the same time different from
traditional software analysis based on
source code and the evolution analysis
cognitive software analysis highly
depends on operation data including
trace log and the matrix our vision uh
for multi-dimensional analysis of
cloudative software including that uh
operation data analysis can be used a
means for observing and governing the
cloud native software ecosystem and at
the same time the so-called ai ops may
need to extend its focus to include such
as architecture the decades and the
business review recovery and we need to
consider to introduce more and the
richer operation data by new sensors to
improve the observability and also we
need to consider to use more intelligent
operation data analysis techniques by
combining trace log and matrix thanks